now well if you weren't already hungry
this is going to do it we're talking big
game grub distilling remedies sharing
their queso dip recipe
to be sure to score a touchdown with
your guests this sunday
we are talking big game recipes i am in
the kitchen this is still in remedy they
have several locations across the valley
but this is the new one this is just
still offering about chef jack we are
cooking up some good stuff today
absolutely spicy
definitely well you know today i'm going
to be doing a brisket uh queso okay you
know with the super bowl coming up
there's going to be lots of brisket left
over hopefully with the tailgating
season right the smart way to use that
is uh turn it into a queso turn it into
a dip you know add some cream cheese
cheddar cheese some charred corn some
jalapenos and take that chopped brisket
and just throw it in there cook it down
for about 20 minutes
and then take the rest of your brisket
get it nice and crispy kind of like
burnt ends finish it with some barbecue
sauce
and that's going to go right on the very
top kind of like a garnish you know
let's say you're you're not fancy and
you need to throw in some velveeta there
it's just gonna taste a little different
different yeah okay but hey if that's
what you want you're 100 people i'm not
telling you what to do yeah absolutely
for me cheddar's better oh cheddar's
better i like that plan all right so how
do we serve it up so yeah so what we're
gonna do is we've got our house made
kettle chips buy your favorite flavor
salt pepper
you know whatever whatever you what you
want to do or you can buy them already
pre-made with the barbecue seasoning on
them that's totally okay as well
so once you get them in your bowl we're
just going to take our seasoning and
kind of toss it together
now what's the key to not burning this
because i always burn cheese all right
you know with my thing is if you're
going to walk away for even five minutes
you want to go low and slow just nice
low low heat not even medium just low
and slow and keep whisking it we're
going to take some green onions to
finish
a little bit of cotija cheese
boom and a char jalapeno
and that's it should we try it yeah
absolutely all right
quick change
we saw that earlier in the week you can
find this recipe and all the big game
grub online 8newsnow.com
and tomorrow on good day las vegas wake
up early it's so worth it we're going to
have soul belly back for another simple
dish you can make for your super bowl
party